alright let's talk about prop 8 we can't
do one week without something gay and
this one I think is actually kind of
interesting sir charles cooper who is
one of the lawyers that was for prop 8
meaning he was against marriage equality
and fought it at the Supreme Court we're
not going to believe this he has
flip-flopped and yeah he's now for gay
marriage why well his step daughter
lesbian wants to get married incredible
how this works out we've got a quote
from general Cooper my views above on
issues of this kind the same way as
other people's do and how I view this
down the road may not be the way I view
it now or how I viewed it 10 years ago
thats attorney Charles Cooper died so
basically that seems good to me he's
trying to get on the right side of
history except the Supreme Court case
wasn't that long ago and is it a little
disingenuous like now it affected you
personally so you're gonna get on the
right side like this kind of in a weird
way I'm happy that happened but it kind
of seems like a dick move active week so
judge him right so I got yeah we can
totally judge him yeah no more to this
are you gone by with it I mean good for
him but I confirm ? yeah like good for
you that you personally affected you and
now you're deciding that you have to not
be an yeah can you guys at
BuzzFeed do some sort of one of those
what do you call them the freaking tests
the you know where the quiz is that can
you do one of the quizzes on like how
you evolved on gay marriage with all
your crazy can you make go do not write
please after the show may God really I
mean I look it's good he did it but like
it's literally about what is it about a
year later something maybe it so it's
less than a year later it's like nine
months later and it seems like well it
affected you personally so now you're
gonna come on board like it it blows my
mind that there are still people in this
country who don't see that this war has
been lost by them like bigots have lost
this war it's just going to happen it's
not there's no going back now and two
it's it's the equivalent of being a
segregationist in 1982 like it's you it
the wars done right and so the fact
what's more shocking me is that there
are there are so many people who haven't
evolved their stance on gay
so should we graciously accept this guy
should be like yeah sure you fought you
fought against us less than a year ago
in the Supreme Court but you found out
you have a lesbian stepdaughter
welcoming I think they were so excited
thinking well I we are accepting but I
also think it's a great feather in the
cap of the cause that if even this guy i
mean this is this is darth vader like
hanging out with the Ewoks like it's
it's impossible to be touched by this
issue personally and not come to the
right conclusion if Dick Cheney who I'm
pretty sure is an evil robot sent from
the future can be for gay marriage
because his daughter is then really it's
the least you can ask if somebody it's
actually the least you can so is this
just proof that the number one thing the
gay people can do is come out because
look it happened with Dick Cheney when
his daughter came out he came around
this guy's daughter came out we had that
was abroad porter i think senator his
son came out so so it's basically like
if you come out you can pretty much
affect the the convictions politician am
the positive way of thinking about it
yeah instead of being like sri be
gracious which know we will yes we
should be gracious but should we just
accept that should the game you just
accept all these people no matter what
they've done in their past should the
second you change should you be uh
exonerated a boy I don't think she like
marching in the pride parade but we can
like we can hate him lat we can accept
that he evolved on the issue without
making him like a you know a gay icon
yeah I know if he wants to be a gay icon
but I think we should maybe not make him
won't have to morph into an old lady
probably should wear away yeah but I
think no no um do you think it matters
even if he's not doing this necessarily
cause of his daughter but just for
selling a book cuz I think that's also
part of it like how do you sell your
book while I was the property lawyer
before it against gay marriage and now
I'm for it let's sell a book you know
like there's some element but should we
even take that and do that I I think
whatever gets people on the right side
of this issue is a good thing and I
don't think that makes them great people
because I don't think this issue makes
being for gay marriage and saying that
people who love each other should be
able to get married doesn't make you a
good person that's just what as people
we should expect of each other
you know one extra credit yeah yeah well
I mean I would love some extra credit
given a metric reddit this whole time
will you yeah totally for being at ya
and Ally for being an hour you know I I
do what I can yep uh does anyone involve
the other way that that's what this is
making me think is there anyone that's
pro-gay marriage that suddenly have we
heard that at all as maybe that went to
Berkeley which is a very liberal school
but the largest group on campus are
actually called Republicans because
people come we're like moderate and
they're so freaked out by the liberalism
that they like backtrack and become
these really conservative like
so I feel like that could happen like
some I get so scared about like it
marriage equality like I'm gonna just a
minute like double down and become like
super anti after thinking this was okay
yeah isn't that a little bit of like the
chick-fil-a theory like the more you
fought the more the gays for chick-fil-a
the more chicken they sold like a little
bit of that or the more that they fought
duck dynasty suddenly the ratings were
huge now I guess they're not okay to
call Paula Deen still people rally
behind Paula Deen every time she says
some cases that what happens read for
her brand yeah now no I I think when
people will begin to devolve on this
issue to devolve on this issue when gay
divorce starts starts popping up you'll
see a lot of gay people who will be like
you know like I don't know if it was
right for me you know gay marriage in
theory is great but yeah I want to go
back to the single I do have a friend
right now that's a lesbian in the middle
of a divorce and I feel like it's very
that's very edgy what do you think
that's my teeny horse first though you
know they had a divorce lesbian divorce
they get married first two they got a
very first day divorce first yeah
there's some what u haul joke were
supposed yeah I've walked up to the edge
of it and turned around go he's not a
good Ally he's not gonna make that joke
you